cela fait déjà plusieurs mois que la
région dekive est constamment bombardée
par l'armée russe mais les frappes de la
nuit dernière ont notamment atteint une
clinique et des bâtiments résidentiels
pour le chef de la police de la région
la population civile est ciblée
délibérément les cibles civiles
indiquent que cette attaque est un acte
terroriste dans le but d'intimider la
population de tuer des civil ce est un
génocide lesust en intensité depuis
quelques semaines à tel point que 26
villages de la région frontalière de
koupiansk ont été évacués mardi en
représaill l'Ukraine multiplie ses
attaques de drone en territoire russe
notamment sur la ville frontalière de
belgorode et celle plus éloignée de
voreneig où se situe une base aérienne
ils essaient de montrer qu'ils peuvent
aussi faire quelque chose mais au lieu
de résoudre leurs problèmes militaire
ils agissent de manière tellement
barbare ils attaquent des zones peuplées
pacifiques avec des armes aveugles
keV veut chasser la Russie de son ciel
car pour le ministre ukrainien des
Affaires étrangères celui qui contrôlera
les air déterminera quand et comment la
guerre se
terminera pour se faire il faudra
fournir à l'Ukraine des avions F16 des
missiles à longue portée des drones et
bien sûr des moyens de guerre
électronique si tout cela arrive nous
continuerons à gagner et à libérer des
territoires mais nous combattons un
ennemi puissant et cet ennemi ne dort
pas du
temps les États-Unis et l'Union
européenne ont de nouveau réitéré leur
soutien à l'Ukraine lors du sommet de
Davos la Hongrie se disant même prête à
prendre sa part sur son propre budget
quelques heures plus tard la France
annonçait la livraison de 40 nouveaux
missiles long porté scalp et de
centaines de bombes